[Music]
you said that Jamaica is your favorite
Real Housewives memory and your time on
the show it really was I have that means
because the last trips I went to Iceland
was cool
I had a great time there but I don't
like cold but it was a great experience
don't get me wrong
Ireland was a nightmare makeup was fun I
just had a great time in Jamaica
starting with Vicki confesses that she
needs sex four times a day it's like I'm
high battle all your time hey Steve have
a high libido you can hey she's a nympho
yeah I know yeah but I know you have to
have a take on that that's a lot of
times in one day and I know she's really
like that because she's jaurim can I say
but is she doing it that many times a
day with Steve I I don't know I didn't
do it don't even want to know I mean I
can't even put that vision in my head or
else
yeah here cheers Cheers yeah
bottoms up that's a lot to take in
so we don't want to picture Vicki having
sex more times a day but you and Tamra
do focus in a lot on her butt down to
the bottom of her bottom what happened I
mean I never realized that she had a
badunkadunk like that I mean that thing
is round and hard and I mean I know she
doesn't work out all that often I mean
we were shocked I think it was up high
and lifted and hard did you ever get an
answer on whether he said yeah she said
she has not had any surgeries or
anything at all do you believe her no
okay but then things take kind of a left
turn from fun to drama in Jamaica
Shannon kind of unravels
walk me through en hinges
yeah he does unhinge she's no time for
you don't put words in my mouth
Tamra will tell you I am a very good
friend to her okay let's let's hammer
Taher why did things get so bad with
Shannon in Jamaica I mean I in hindsight
I think we should have been a bit a
little more you know empathetic towards
towards Shannon but you know Shannon was
caught up all in her drama and wasn't
really asking about other people and how
they were doing it was all about her and
you could see that she was kind of you
know kind of getting out of control
there a little bit it was all about
Shannon and then we were hearing it from
the girls you know she wasn't being nice
to them and it was like buh buh buh buh
buh buh bah it was like a lot of noise
and we just I just
in hindsight I feel bad that that
Shannon got oh you know yeah but Shannon
didn't have to react that way either
stop it
she storms off tells the cameras to stop
filming her then you guys are all in a
room together where she and Tamra really
get into it right what was it like to be
in that room and see those two going at
it I thought that Shannon was gonna get
a heart attack or like a stroke I
thought something horrific was gonna
happen to her because she was so
emotional and like upset and screaming
and crying it was it was too much and
then she basically cuts the group off
Isis everybody out and you know I mean I
felt bad for her like at least we tried
to have her you know come and hang out
with us and asked how she was doing she
chose to isolate herself and she
basically misses out on the rest of the
trip it seems yes you could had a great
time I had a great time you and Tamra
saying all of the [ __ ] and stuff that
she basically would call you guys
non-stop until one of you would pick up
like every night of the week what
happened when you guys got back from
Jamaica did she stop oh yeah she
completes stop calling I think she got
the memo she doesn't do it anymore where
do you and Shannon stand today
friendship wise you're in a good place
we're really good
okay she tried to hook me up with her
friends you know she calls me once to
have lunch dinner she yeah she's she's I
talk to her all the time when you think
back three years ago when you first met
Shannon
there was no way I'm like first of all I
couldn't think of anything in common
with this lady like you know I thought
she was a little pretentious a little
you know just rude freaking what you are
you are despicable but turns out I was
totally faking this is awesome
where do things go with the group and
Shannon after Jamaica the group you know
is kind of divided but yet we all make
amends at the end
[Music]